I hear you like to arm-wrestle is that
true oh we're doing that oh I know you
would win immediately might see you've
already won I can't this is all bicep
right here Jefferson over the top yeah
okay Kristin Kristin would still beat
him with yes she would beat me she has
powers you had an idea for something to
do with laundry a way to fix damaged
laundry is that right yeah yeah well let
me zip up my fly here there we go that
was a part of the gag coming out but it
didn't work
um anyways so yes logic did you note I
didn't notice that his flight was that I
did a couple minutes ago and I was just
stairs gonna wait to say something but
you know I didn't want to interrupt the
whole you know cops episode okay good a
good invention so in my book I got about
50 random ones I had so so okay I I shop
a lot I used to shop at thrift stores
all the time and I loved it but I always
thought baby clothes were the coolest
cuz they have a lot of character and
they look really cool and you like you
like bait the clothes babies where you
think of the coolest clothes this is the
whole right side brain probably doesn't
make sense a lot of people but um yes
and I shrink my I'm a terrible
washer dryer whatever shrinks your
clothes it's not I'm not good at washing
and followed by too much drawing which
tends to heat on he yeah it does it so I
was thinking why can't you have an
expander like a drying machine but
expands the follicles of your fabrics
because it's not like you're you're
you're losing fabrications right it's
just that there's getting shrunken and
getting really tight so you're closer
but if you had an expander I can buy my
baby clothes saved money cuz it's
cheaper and then just throw it in this
expanding have some cool cool treads
away what are you talking about
the present children where I have little
kids they're closer absurd you don't
want to walk around in those clothes
we wouldn't have to worry about your fly
being open you have to worry about your
crotch being on it make life for the
trapdoor in your button open so you
really want to wear those clothes this
is fascinating studies want to expand my
follicles of my fabrications
that's what cuz that spring my clothes
so they're not like like you said Jacque
and my arms are too big and it's like
he's always trying to show off yes tight
clothes no I did it on accident that's
my favorite shirt we have always buy
them in the correct side yeah I like you
kelan but this is a fascinating
interview I'm learning so much we must
get we have a clip here from the
Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn Part 2 and I
believe this is a clip where you're
dressed as an adult you would think
you'll see this my shirt my shirt is is
a child shirt it's a bit tight okay
anything else we need to know for this
clip you don't want to know
fascinating let's take a look
[Music]
well done Bella never seen a newborn
show that kind of restraint I'm not sure
she is a newborn
she's so tame didn't don't antagonize
her she the strongest one in the house
please all right yourself Emmett
[Music]
I'll three
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
man
[Applause]
you're not as strong as your left hand I
pick you down so fast